tenemos la ecuación tres cuartos de x +
2 es igual a
tres octavos de x menos cuatro podríamos
resolver esta ecuación como lo hacemos
usualmente agrupando los términos en x
quizás del lado izquierdo y las
constantes del lado derecho pero las
sumas y restas de fracciones en
ocasiones se complican así es que lo que
voy a hacer desde el principio en este
vídeo es multiplicar ambos lados de la
ecuación por un número para eliminar las
fracciones y la mejor manera de hacerlo
es cuál es el número más pequeño que si
yo multiplico ambos lados de la ecuación
por él se eliminan las fracciones se
hacen números enteros pues bien ese
número más pequeño es 8 el número más
pequeño es 8 voy a multiplicar a ambos
lados de esta ecuación por 8 me puedes
preguntar oye sal y cómo obtuviste el 8
obtuve el 8 porque encontré el mínimo
común múltiplo de 4 y 8 el número más
pequeño que es divisible entre 4 y 8 es
8 así es que cuando multiplicamos por 8
vamos a deshacernos de las fracciones
veámoslo 8 por 3 cuartos es 8 por 3
entre 4 lo voy a hacer aquí a un lado
entonces tenemos 8 por 3 entre 4 esto es
igual
esto es 8 entre 4 es 2 nos queda dos por
tres es igual a 6 así es que 8 por 3
cuartos de x es igual a 6 x + 8 por 2 +
8 por 2 16 acuérdate que cuando
multiplicamos todo un lado de la
ecuación por un número tienes que
distribuir ese número
así es que 8 por 2 es 16 y el lado
izquierdo de 6 x 16 esto es igual a 8
por 3 octavos de x estos 8 se cancelan y
nos quedan simplemente 3x menos 8 por 4
32 3x menos 32 y ya tenemos una ecuación
más cómoda ahora agrupemos términos en x
del lado izquierdo y las constantes del
lado derecho eliminemos 3x del lado
derecho para esto restemos 3 x el lado
derecho y también lo tenemos que hacer
del lado izquierdo restamos 3 x ambos
lados es la mejor manera de eliminar ese
3x que tenemos de lado derecho y que nos
resulta del lado izquierdo de 6 x menos
3 x es igual a 3 x 6 menos
33 + 16 y esto va a ser igual a 3 x
menos 3 x es igual a 0 por eso hicimos
todo esto de tal manera que sólo nos
queda la constante que es menos 32 bien
ahora eliminemos este 16 del lado
izquierdo para eso prestemos 16 del lado
izquierdo y también lo restamos del lado
derecho que nos resulta del lado
izquierdo nos queda 3x que se mantiene
16 menos 16 30 por eso hicimos esto y
del lado derecho nos va a quedar menos
32 menos 16 esto es igual a menos 48
ahora vamos a despejar la x para esto
dividimos entre 3 dividimos entre 3 del
lado izquierdo y dividimos entre 3 del
lado derecho del lado izquierdo nos
queda 3 entre 3 es igual a 1 esto es
igual a x y del lado derecho nos queda
menos 48 entre 3 esto es igual a menos
16 y ya hemos terminado
es igual a menos 16 es la solución de
nuestra ecuación veamos que este valor
de x realmente funciona para la ecuación
original
la ecuación original no tenía esos ochos
a ambos lados sustituyamos entonces en
la ecuación original tenemos entonces
que tres cuartos que multiplica a x que
es menos 16 más 2 tiene que ser igual a
3 octavos que multiplica a menos 16 - 4
menos cuatro que nos da esto tres
cuartos por menos 16 tenemos aquí menos
16 entre 4 que sería menos 4
esto sería entonces 3 x menos 43 x menos
4 es igual a menos 12 menos 12 + 2 menos
12 2 tenemos del lado izquierdo que es
igual a menos 10 y del lado derecho que
tenemos de lado derecho tenemos 3
octavos por menos 16 menos 16 entre 8 es
igual a menos 2
así es que esto de aquí es 3 x menos 2
que es igual a menos seis menos cuatro
menos seis menos cuatro es igual a menos
diez así es que cuando x es igual a
menos 16 se cumple la ecuación original
pues ambos lados son iguales a menos 10
y así hemos concluido